welcome my name is means that
i will also have i am a
product manager at google in security and i
am joined here by kénitra hello my
name is done nitra ravelomanantsoa i
am strategic fost lead at google
my team works on the protection
of  personal data is
currently on the jdp r here I leave
you first with maya and I will come
right away perfect so as
my role as product manager I work
in particular on encryptions but
really everything that  is
data protection at google
I've
been with us for a few years now good so to
give you a little more context we
already talked about it this morning but you know
the citation of google products in
business we of course have
applications  starts consumers but
also a business offer with jsui
such as gmail calendar etc etc with
news of the stone age and keuning
anyway google security starts
v
we have no longer have this
consumer application and in addition
to a billion monthly users
such as grimé in android and chrome
securing its applications has
required significant investments
on our part  to be
able to level to ignore new
products is also an investment
the scale to be able to secure
so many users so as
the company intends that for our
enterprise customers we understand that by
using google cloud you want to have
and  you can have the and benefit from the
same investment we have made
to protect your users
what does that mean what do
we aim to do at new believe
in times of hardship and security what we
really target c  is to be your
trusted partner in security and
on that we really have three axes the
cominak on three points the first
is security  by default we've talked about
a little are very interested in but
your cloud provider should
secure your data to a minimal level
by default in an easy to manage
and in-depth way and at google that's what
we aim to do in all  our
products are consumers are
businesses secondly transparency
we will recognize that trust
is not only achieved through
technology but through transparency
we aim to give us as
much information to give you as
much information as possible about security
privacy  of our products and
your data with us for and for a
few months we have several
white papers on our website that you
can read which went into a lot more
detail on how we do this
at google and lately innovation
and shared responsibility
security using the cloud
you should be able to unlock
the scale you need to
solve any  whatever problem
you want but if you
are not a security company
you won't have to spend time on it it
should be handled for you it's very
easy for you it's tomorrow it's
a  area where crab vendors
and other security tools need to
master for 14 to serve you to
review some of these points a bit more
first on the
default internet
security google security just has to work it
really wants  to say that security is
integrated at several levels by default
deep into each of our products
and at several levels of
software support and that which we saw this morning I will
go through in a second and
secondly this security must
really be practical  for
google engineering teams secure secure
for google security teams
is also simple enough for a
consumer to use face-to-face and that's
how we developed more  some
of our best products and
for our customers
for example the safety nets
you see on the screen it's not
something that google doesn't produce but it's
an option in
two factor authentication  which has been tested with
several gougaud employees close to our
employees in order to find a solution
that we and not between non-intrusive quick
to use and safe it is an
experience that we can share with you
thanks to our knowledge on the
second point  relay the point
of transparency trust through
transparency and not just through
technology to this sentence
had been introduced at gougaud by our
security product manager ignore this
about what you see on the screen
alive in the crab your  company
needs more details on
how your provider
cloud providers google chrome
on secures its products services and
indeed anything related to your data
open  on how we do this
in white papers in mail boxes
in everything we do it's
really a big step in that
trust all of that to say so I
was giving you a bit of an overview what is
we would really like to secure
your information and your data what
do we do differently at google
no I actually wanted to go into the
technical details now to
give you a little more but all that
I'm going to talk about today is  it's at this
link here it's a it's a white paper
on what's called google either that what
design and after about 30 30
pages that goes through several
levels which I'm going to discuss right
now
so  to start you give an
overview of our software stack and the
security present at each level
this is what we do to ensure
in-depth security we invest
at all levels from
hardware security to  use of the
services is in fact  t which software games
to target certain technologies which are
more interesting to share
even a little more detail the
first interesting thing to note
is that this that it acts sky at
nineteen levels
it is a little different from what  you
see with our competitors as
the lower levels the hardware
the boot the system operators and the
storage for which the protection and
the responsibility of google to
join come back to the point
before we give you more
transparency and information on these
protections and how we're
securing them for you by default so to blow
it up exposed that in a bigger picture
we have our mom brief of all the
steps google takes to protect
your products your services at its nine
levels each box represents an
area of interest  for our security teams
it is an important mapping of
some of the security features
at the user platform level  n
belt against these nine levels at
second trip software do
n't try all now i know there
are a lot of people
taking pictures but i'm going through
several points in the next few minutes
so to start at  first level
with our own hardware
gogaud builds its own
data centers and this includes the custom design
of our own chips our own
servers and our own storage we
lay our own fiber for our
own network and this includes the
largest transpacific cables  of the
world building our own hardware
makes it possible to create an infrastructure that
precisely meets our requirements, in
particular those 12 what we
need for security and of course it
also has advantages for our
performance
an example of hardware designed
specifically for security  it's the
tighten chip that you also
heard about this morning at the cinema with a
suddenly it's a chip that is
custom made that we are going to create ourselves
to restore a root of trust
hardware world truck
that allows us to do three interesting things
the first is to check for
each server in our
data centers  on which we put a chip
which are really
google servers because the cus allows us to
verify
the identification and authentication
of legitimate gougaud peripheries at
the hardware level
the second thing is for
applications that they preview these  machines
there to use the tighten chip to
safeguard certain sensitive data
for example keys only intended
for this particular application
and thirdly it is for the
secure batch boot secure doubt that with because
with title we have a solid base
for this  process secure boot
and a list athens to sign and
verify the bootloader it would make
sure it's really part of the stack
software from google
so it's by signing every
startup process tighten also gives a
cryptographic identity to the system that
's on that machine there to the
applications that they have on that
machine has so that it was kinda on
the hardware and  the boot
now at level 2 the system
operators and
internal process communications I'm going to talk a little
more about interprocess communications
because it's really one of the
most interesting parts
of gogo's infrastructure inside inside
google's infrastructure all applications are
containerized and all of those containers
are treated as
independent services so we
basically designed our
platform to be a multi-
tenant system from the start and we
're not assuming any trust
between  its services
even if the seat operates on the same
machine there are four ways in
particular for communications is
a service i was talking about
first is the identity the
only of the service as i
mentioned before each service has its own
identity
this allows us to enforce
cryptographic authentication and authorization at
the application level
each service that  run on
the infrastructure receives cryptographic credentials
that use it in particular automatically
to prove its identity to other
services
so each
procedure call from ad meaning
events cross precise or imprecise
this allows  customers to ensure that
they are really talking to the server provided
so in service only by another service
can check the antilles the of this
service there secondly the encryption of
interservice communications so
beyond notifications there is a
railcar authorization from which I come  to
speak
we can also encrypt procedure calls
to ten years for
confidentiality and integrity
crypt  graphic to extend its
advantages to other parts of the
system such as http calls
we encapsulate them in our
dropped system so we can in fact give
it is this level of protection in
several parts of our
infrastructure and  this allows us
to isolate the application layer to
remove any dependency on
lower levels such as the network
consequently
encrypted and secure inter-service communication remained
qu ized even if the network is exploited
so we do not need  to have even yes
we have our own network but if we
don't want to and trust
the communications are still
encrypted on this network there so in
particular at google chrome what is
happening with our artists
and infrastructures between our
data centers  is that they are
automatically encrypted by the network
without requiring the explicit configuration
explained by the service so
not only do we do that
automatically
but opposite it also offers at the level of the
network whose service itself does
not have to manage anything to ensure that these
occur thirdly the management of
the internet access service
the infrastructure allows a
service owner to specify
exactly  who can communicate with
it so for example a
storage service will have certain api who wants to
offer only certain other
services he can describe a
whitelist of other services who can
communicate with him and that also once
again and in force and through the network
itself and not by this service was
automatically applied by
the infrastructure
so you see a bit of a system where the drive-through service is
not given
the authority to make their own choices
monfort ski service to do that  in
our infrastructure and lately
finally let's talk a bit about the management
of access to user data
so in the event that a service has access to
user data like how
is it  that he knows that a call coming
from another service of andré call how
does he know that there is really
the end user to what requested
this data and the data in
particular of this user
there for example  when the gmail service
sends a request to a
storage service on behalf of so
it yielded in particular what happens
is that the infrastructure provided
to the service mans a
users authorization ticket end-user
trickett
in the  case of the rpc which can therefore be
presented to other services that
need to respond to the request
this ticket lasts only a few
minutes so we can limit the amount of milk
to quote in particular and the services
only return the information related
to the users who are named in this
ticket  therefore limit access to
intra service data it was a bit on
internal communications were in
service to talk to the next level
level of storage did several
c  hoses of course to protect
data at storage
one of those to stop causes and
access will be opened by manage
red sox to make sure they only
have access to data is authorized and
keep so that we  can see them later
but one thing in particular that we do
is encryption and that's my specialty
so we'll talk a little bit more if
you but if you let me so
what are we doing interesting  with
us at google
in fact what we want aims to do is
give you options for how to
process your data and allows you to
encrypt your data at home as
you do it
brandon with us as you
already do at home or  the club so one of the
options fox to the left to
start with is the default encryption
that you believe to crypts your data
stored at rest with no
required client intervention using
multiple
tier mechanisms we have published a white paper
just on this topic  on the c  google encryption
on the website which describes the
process in great detail
if security is not your
strong point or if you have no special requirements
for your encryption or
key management this is the solution  which is right for
you this is the solution for
you in the middle we have in the center we have our
google chrome service which management
/s with what we call
customer managed keys you can generate
use tour and destroy encryption keys
which  belong to you on
google phone and if you need
more to manage your own encryption keys this
is the solution for you and
lately on the right we have our option
which is called customer provided keys
here you provide agoco a key
encryption used to protect an object
for example a gogo crowd storage an
image persistent indices an instance
of a gourcuff wendel libya what you
provide us are kept at
google
when memory they are not  t not described to
disk
if you need to generate your
own encryption keys or to generate
your own and clipping at home this is the
solution for you so
how does it
actually work how does this  may have encrypted
data by default at google
but first of all this is how we
store data at google man
when you give us an object to
store
that object is first torn into
pieces and distributed through our
infrastructure to be stored
data is atomized across our
infrastructure each chunk is encrypted
with an individual clients such
that chunks do not have the same key
even though they are part of the same object
even though they belong to the same
clients and even though they are on  the same
machine
if an object has update the pieces
of this data are encrypted with a
new fact rather to challenge the same
key this partition to give at a
really low level with each  ue piece
students a different key
ensures blast radius of potential compromise
unlimited encryption units
only one piece of data each
piece of data has
unique catr identifies art 6 access control lists
against  46 that each piece
can only be described and that by the
google services running is authorized to
which access is granted at that
time and as I have already spoken
before about our internal
communication art pc system this is really what
we can do with this process there we
can verify that it is really a
request that must be done at this
time this prevents access to
data without authorization and after
each piece is distributed through
the cult instance of atomized gourgan
distributed for storage and replicated
against the backdrop of encrypt for
backup reintegration of in the event of a disaster
a person a malicious person
wishing to access the data of a
client must therefore a find all the
pieces that have been in the pieces
of data which sorry find all the
pieces of data that are part in
the particular region find in the
google system where its pieces of
data are stored
which is really a  very
difficult problem and also having access to
loans and pieces of data will
be able to access them
so all of this together it will be that
accessing this delay is very
difficult for a 4 4 that kills them if
you have nothing to do nothing  other
than just that for data at google
they are already encrypted at rest
this is what differentiates us from our
crab competitors not going to do anything
to ensure that your data is already
encrypted so come back to our stack
that we  was not right for example
our software stack I now add at the
level of the neutral network infrastructures
says our sweat is a more private space of ideas
and therefore isolated from the rest
the internet to access  to resources
that there is a single point of entry what
is called the google phone and or the
jean the djinn phyllis ruby globally but p
ovides a single point of lo
ical applications for all traff
c entering google in the conte
t of  'a multi-
tenant institution like we have at google
chrome jeans is really just another
service and girl can therefore
has evolved to match volumes
of incoming requests
we can have more jerry - jefferies
co indeed need everything  indian service
which is externally accessible used
jeeha fip as an end of ruz
proxy before the service can be
available on the internet
it must first register with the fnj
efi provided several things and including for
example hosting ip addresses
dienné domain name server
protection against denial of service
10h traction and termination of
encryption which alas of which guarantees that
all connections pull  less that
are secure there are secure and one in
a certificate of ra that with 2048 head and take
advantage if possible when the djia
girl receives a request he has forwarded
to the corresponding services study let
the bishop mechanism do not delay it is
secure of which I  I have already spoken
so to talk a little more about how
we can protect google and jefferies
against denial of service attacks
the first defense is really
the scale of our will especially google
we are so big that we can
really simply  absorbing
many attacks from a service we
absorb denials of service it's crazy
remember that when I talked
about custom materials that's where we
really have the advantages or land forming
this at the level of our network however
it's not the only thing we do
we have other options to
secure ourselves for attacks were in
service
so each external connection we are
looking for a gogo service must go
through several  urs several layers
of moldavian load balancing
answers 6 balancer provides its
statistics on one on the traffic
a central service of 10 dances and
when they detect an attack which by
a denial of service this
central service can re communicate with its
scouts  to reduce or limit the
traffic associated with attack
in addition to that the instances i have done
itself communicates with the
central didace case service and as they
can they can see other
traffic information
for example what is it  what's
happening at the sting level
and lately as a google customer
playing our google browser service
the overall cost will actually be that part
of the gfi so you can get the
same 10 year protection by putting
your service behind  le coq banded dress
if you don't trust you
prefer a partner we also have
many who can make similar offers
I would like a few diapers p  We go
to the user level
so r10 user errors
are always possible and can
always lead to things like
security issues in particular what we see
is really phishing attacks
or spear phishing
even if  the infrastructure is
perfectly secure and partially
completely patched with no exploitable vulnerabilities
it doesn't matter if the attacker can just
enter as a normal user if
not enter through the front door
that's the problem with sin then
double checking  steps with
a security key provides a higher level of
protection with
validation for example with
etrex footage especially in europe we
see attacks on
second level verification on etrex footage
so please change inaugura
union but if  you want to change
something like this
a return to cannes by heart the cries of
security as I have already mentioned
before  vant
it's not something you go for
but it's something that's been tested
at the top weight close to 60000 google
what con found that was
the easiest most effective way best
protected against attacks  of phishing
he sees proof of it a
cryptographic prod that the users
are on a legitimate site and that they
have their security keys with them so
alain term of gogo that's what we do
we were just and key for s  ensuring
they are actually communicating with
real google services is a
practice we have mandated
for several years now and
to actually access a service a
user is provided with a page of
two logins asking on behalf
of  user is also a
password and this site can also appeal
to children
additional information such as a
tunic and security key this is done
dynamically
so in case there is no d  e
detection that we do not know so we
do not detect when the password is not
sufficient given the history 17
are connection sessions we can
mandate a key of Cléty korité
similarly as administrator
of gogos kroll us  offer you the same
functionality in terms of our product
security a fork
that allows you to require the use
of such a security key or in
our second factor for you
employ for better protection
against phishing attacks
so i have  went through pretty quickly anyway
but to get back to those to
these can review all of this together and
take your photos it's really
at google infrastructure and u19 level
compared to a traditional software stack
in which we
have solutions  to protect your
applications your users and your
data in particular the
lower levels the hardware the boot the operating system
and the storage it is our
responsibility and we take care of it
that we give you a lot of information
on our website through conferences
like that you can talk to me afterwards
to secure your data and part of the duo
starts from the network to
the user
that's it  is a shared responsibility we
do a lot to already protect you
but if you want to do other
things
you can do it on the other hand we
make sure that you are secure by default
you already have a minimum level of
security
so I hope that this  transparency to
help give you a little more
confidence about the security of gobo the
privacy of your data
as i mentioned before
a white paper on the website but
now i'm going to leave you with my
colleague daughter will be born who will talk
to you about compliance  de gogui proof
here is hello to all so maillard
presented you in fact the expertise of our
teams to take you to secure solutions
and now we are going to
return to da  ns a focus on
compliance with laws and
regulations when you use
our services and in particular on the
protection of personal data
so rest assured we are not leaving
you alone on these issues you
can count on google when it
comes  to implement
compliance solutions and also to help
you comply with your own requirements
so this is what we are going to discuss
today we will first see how
you can conduct this impact analysis
this study of this evaluation  the
compliance of our solutions
we are going to discuss the
information documents that we make available to
you to carry out this 6
min
finally we are going to see the document from
which our commitments are derived our
obligations
we are going to talk about the contracts and make a
small focus on the project the
European regulation which will arrive therefore which will
come into force next year on
the protection of personal data
on  famous art gp d where looters
for general data protection and
regulations we will start with the
campaign part years
assessments analysis conformity assessment
the idea here is not to list
all the laws and regulations that
may apply and which may
impact you and when you use the
cloud
there are a lot of them in twenty minutes we
will be able to list them all
in fact it will depend on a lot of
things on the type of data you
use from customers in your location
location of your type of industry
there are hundreds of thousands of
possible combinations there
is no point delisting
today so how can we do it
in fact we are going to talk about
shared responsibility in terms of
compliance
we are going to consider  you know
your industry you are a
professional
you know the data you use
you have an idea of the laws and regul
tions that apply
to it  n of this data
you have your legal department
your responsibility and compliance
you know the contracts that bind you
to your own customers the
commitments you have made here you know
your industry we at google we have
known about the cloud
it has been a long time now
when we  made of the cloud we were born in it
we have a good knowledge of the
regulations applicable to the cloud and
in has the technical expertise maya
show it to you to meet these requirements
I go back
so all this will create a shared responsibility
you will be responsible for the
how you conduct your business
and we take responsibility
for the infrastructure and the conditions
for this shared responsibility to
work, in fact, we will
provide you with the elements that
will allow you to evaluate our
solution  check that it is
in accordance with the use
you intend to make and that is what we
have  Let's see today I wanted
to list you on 7
slides the different questions
you should ask yourself when you are going to
use the cloud etc and in particular our
cloud system you are going to look at
what security
conditions are applicable to  the platform
we saw an overview with maya the moment
you are going to look at whether there are regular audits
carried out by third parties to
verify that what two cloud providers are
committed to and well applied
you are also going to look at the questions
relating to intellectual property
who owns the data is
once you put the data in the
cloud
it still belongs to you at
google has taken the position of
considering that your data
belongs to you even if you
use it in our structure phase
l  'infrastructure belongs to us you
give you finally belong to the
questions relating to the use of the
data how the supplier  use
the data
are you informed in the event of an
incident do you have the
possibility of recovering the data
and deleting them are they
really deleted from the datacenter and
finally the information relating to
the  hosting starting to store the
data in which country it is
stored
here is a bit of an example of a question
you should ask yourself when you
use a cloud provider
and it's true I really invite you to
carry out this type of evaluation
don't use n  'wasn't going just on google
cloud because we're called google
really carried out this type of exercise which
will allow you to almost justify
to your own
dew regulator says lee jones that you have
carried out so these are the questions that
you have to ask yourself is now
what are the documents that
we make available to you to carry
out this study this analysis we are going to
talk about transparency and above all we are
going to focus on the
third-party audits and the Serbs and the standards
so you see on the badges on the
first level
we are going to talk about the stock reports in fact
why it is interesting and to
simplify as much as possible what the
shock report is
we invite you to find out about the
independent auditors independent third-party auditors
in our data centers they
will come and audit our processes the
controls that we put in place
they will check that what
we committed to in the contract is
properly applied and then they will
draw up a report they will leave  two
types of reports there is the
soc 2 report it is a very detailed report in
fact it is really a report of it is
a 200-page document you
really have all the controls that we
put in place
it is to do  the analogy is where
you have the coca cola recipe this
document is very confidential but
we make it available to you you
can request it when you
are a goo customer  gle cloud via the
admin console to allow you
to conduct the
security assessment that we were
talking about earlier you also have the
report granted which ultimately is a
synopsis of the report except two it is
a document  soc 3 is
publicly available you can watch it
finally you have the iso standards at
google has taken the position
of applying international standards
applicable to our service so we
are certified iso 27001 27000 17 and
27 thousand 18 27 million on the
information system security and 27000 17 and
18 which are really applicable to the cloud
provider on security and
prevention
the idea behind all this is really
to
allow you to see what
are the checks to check that they
are  controls in its standards
the standards that a supplier
must meet before being able to have
this certification is like that it
gives you an idea of what we do
internally we have we follow its
standards we have only been audited
between them and we have obtained
certification on the badges the
icons you see on the bottom these are
more standards let's say regional
private party if schild screen and
contractual clauses  types it will be the
contracts that we also make available to you
and that will allow you to use our
services and in particular to be able to
transfer data from the
European Union to outside the
European Union finally and we already have a  little
discussed before we provide
you with online resources
we have white papers white papers
we have websites dedicated to
certain new questions for
example we have a brand new
website which is really dedicated to jets
dpa regulations on the  data protection
it's something you can
check it we have faqs
by the way the questions that we almost
customers us the most frequently asked questions
uents that we the client made us that
they will allow us
directly to see the most
precise points which will allow you to conduct
this risk assessment on google
cloud
here is once you have done
the compliance assessment and that
I  hope that it has reinforced
your idea that providing us with a solution
capable of meeting your needs in
terms of regulations
you will have to sign a contract to
put all this in writing I will
now present to you by the way the
different contracts that you  you will be required
to sign when you use
google cloud services
there are two three types first there is
the customer agreement made the customer
agreements is going to be the document in
which you will have the commercial elements
it is basically what it is  you
buy and how much it costs
you you will have information on
the conditions
two supports under which conditions
you can benefit from the support  s
google and finally you will have the
legal clauses in the legal on the
responsibility the
intellectual property for example then if
this is necessary and if you
need it within the framework of to meet
your regulatory needs in also offers you
a contract on the protection  data
is my it's my favorite subject a
contract on data protection
it is in this type of contract that you
will have the commitments in fact that
we take in relation to
the use of your data and in
particular the  restrictions that we
provide in relation to the processing of
data
you will have the the conditions
relating to the deletion of data
the commitment that we will indeed
delete your data from our data centers
when you
instruct us to do so the elements relating to
security
we have a whole appendices relating to
security and also the elements relating
to our commitment to continue to have
ourselves audited  only by
independent third parties and to follow the
standards and certifications of
I presented to you previously
and besides that we can have a
third type of endorsement which will cover
the needs according to the country where
you are located and  depending on the
type of activity that you are
going to do
we have for example the closed contract models
say that we put at your
disposal to be able to transfer the
data from europe to do readers from
the european union
it is these  standard contractual clauses
have been validated by three
data protection authorities those of hamburg
dublin and spain you will also
have a specific addendum to for
financial institutions you know that
we have customers in the
banking and insurance sector who have needs
a little more specific to other customers,
particularly in terms of audits by
regulators and we have the famous business
company embellishment which will focus on
the use  health data
rather for companies based in
the united states here are the three levels of
contracts that we will finally have I actually
wanted to finish this
presentation on the g10 looters so the
famous regulation on the protection of
general data data protection and
regulations
just  maybe by raising your hand who has
already heard of the gd father in the
room agree about 90% we will say
of the room who has read the gd father in
full agree about thirty 30 40
percent of the room  here is what
you need to know about the game of fathers
in fact it will come into force next year
on May 25, 2018
it will come to replace an old directive
which dates from 1995 the great father will come to
harmonize the landscape  legislative in
europe on data protection
it will strengthen the rights and
obligations of the persons concerned in
relation to the processing of their data
I did say reinforced by what
the principles at the heart of the protection do  ion
of personal data already existed
in the old directive
they are reinforced by the gpr a
point which is also important and
which is very important to us clarified is
to say that the fact that I have fathers will
be applicable  directly a
supplier previously it was a customer
to ensure that he has the contracts
in place with his supplier to
ensure at all times during the
lifetime of a processing of personal data
the security of the data now an
authority of  data protection will be able to
knock on the door of a
supplier directly and sanction it if it
turns out that it is necessary
we are not going to talk about sanctions I
think you have heard about
it that is also why  the subject has
become a key subject the penalties have
increased considerably
today in French the 250,000 euros
or three hundred thousand in the event of a repeat offense
three hundred thousand euros
tomorrow it will increase up to 20
million eur  os or 4%
of a company's overall turnover that's
a significant increase
the most important point one of the most important points
I have from the Persians
and to stop putting
security really at the heart of a
data processing
is to always ensure that
when we have a treatment the data
are processed are secure from the
collection until the
definitive deletion of the data and finally a point
that is important to us is to specify
that  the gdr is not against the internet
of gd father is not against the cloud
on the contrary it sets up the organist
of the mechanisms to be able to more
easily transfer the
personal data from europe to
the outside of the  europe by ensuring
appropriate measures to always
protect the data during this
transfer so what is our
position that we google cloud in
relation to the dpr jets by the way we
considering that the gdr some
carry challenges brings a lot  a
lot of constraints require a lot
of changes in our products but
it's also an opportunity to
raise the compliance bar to
be really at the top
in terms of compliance and to better
secure the data when you
use our products at google
we have not started the adventure on
data protection not only
with the gdp r it has been now for
several years when we are stupid
working on data protection
for a long time we have offered our
customers the famous living data processing
the contract on data protection
before it was an option when we
will be your customers tomorrow the HQ of the
fathers it will become a
legal obligation to have this type of contract we
offer standard contractual clauses which
we had validated with the
principle of common opinion by three
data protection authorities
it is something that already existed
long before the gdp air and which is taken up
by the  next we will always have we
are always in contact with the
data protection authorities to
apply the recommendations they
issue
and all this has helped us to be
ready and to be able to offer you a
compliance situation from May 25
2018 so here is the key message is that
google is committed to being gdpl compliant
from day one from May 25, 2018
and we are also committed to helping you
on this path to compliance and I
think that one of the ways to
really demonstrating the fact that we are
ready to be in compliance with
the gdp r was the fact that we put online, in line
with our contract, the new
version of the data processing agreements
that we released last week
and which has  been amended with the mandatory clauses
that we which are required
by the gie
tpr we are going to talk about this contract there
so we have released our debt
as possession has really version 2.0
for 10.8 and our  e data prostate after
bastian safe the dip is there for
google cloud platform we released these
contracts last week so
very forward very forward at 13 years old mom of
the effective date of the gdp rgd father arrives
on May 25, 2018 we  let's take out our contracts
now to allow you to assess
our compliance and also to show you
that we are really ready that
we are working on it and that
we are already making commitments on these
points the contract will take effect at the
same time as the gdp r on the 25th  May if
you are a google customer you received
a google cloud hymn you received an
email
last week invite you to
review the contract and accept it
now if you wish here and
it is this contract there as I tell you
take into account the changes
requested by the by the gpr so here
we have seen together today the
elements that will allow you to
carry out an assessment of the conformity of
our services the do  cuments that you
can look at to carry out this
type of assessment we have seen in which
documents entirely to the obligations
in which documents to make the
commitments finally of which we have you
only when you have mineralized today
and we made a last focus  on our
general preparation data protection and
regulations I hope that this session
allowed you to overcome maya this
session allowed you
to be able to carry out this
compliance assessment and reassure you about our
commitment to
regulations and future changes